well the headline for this first story
certainly sounds like I'm jumping on a
right-wing Trope the headline is the
attacks on Free Speech in this country
are rising dramatically and yeah I'm
saying the same thing that right Wingers
are saying except
the attacks are being carried out by the
American right wing and it is yet
another one of these instances of how
projection is the name of the game the
right continuing to accuse the left of
that which they themselves are guilty of
allegations are confessions over
Democrats are going to try to steal an
election in 2020. Democrats didn't
Democrats won but it was those very
Republicans who tried to steal an
election that they did not win they
accused the left but do it themselves
and when it comes to attacks on free
speech that is exactly what we are
seeing we are going to link in the
description to the YouTube clip for this
story
to three different Associated Press
articles with numerous examples of
chilling Free Speech suppressing actions
carried out or attempted by the right
and the categories are numerous you have
the book Banning efforts surging in 2022
according to the Library Association you
have book ban efforts that succeeded at
record numbers in 2021 Florida a
republican-led state by Ron DeSantis and
a republican legislature has the third
largest number of book ban incidents at
schools you have States proposing
restrictions on drag performances and
again you have to understand that all of
these are types of speech artistic
performances community events books that
have been written all of these are forms
of speech
where either the purveyors of the speech
themselves in the case of drag
performers or the uh what would we call
it the conduits to the speech so like a
school library for example are being
told you can't decide for yourself what
to offer and also in many cases parents
can't even decide for themselves because
remember when you have a drag
performance you were leaving it up to
the performers to organize the event but
when it comes to things like drag time
story hour or whatever the case may be
you were leaving it up to the parents to
decide for themselves without the
oppressive hand of government
uh whether they want to take their kids
to such a performance or not and you see
speech limited or attempted to be
limited almost exclusively by
Republicans all over the country we
talked a little bit about that Tennessee
bill which is functioning by
categorizing drag performances as adult
performances equivalent to for example a
strip club and then Banning such
performances from any place where there
could be minors and from all public
properties so if you think wow drag time
story hour at a park
there could be minors and it's public
property it is banned in Idaho we saw an
Art Exhibit censored and teens told they
couldn't testify in some legislative
hearings back to Florida there's this
proposal we talked about to make
bloggers register if they write or plan
to write posts articles uh criticizing
elected officials also in Florida we saw
Ron DeSantis poll Hyatt regency's liquor
license Hyatt Regency is a hotel the
liquor license was pulled right after
they did a drag show where there were
children there nobody coerced parents
saying let's go to this event these are
all efforts by right Wingers not some
but all now can we find equivalent
efforts by the left you know I looked
there there was a bill proposed in
Washington to have like some kind of
bias reporting line and I believe a
Democrat co-sponsored it but it didn't
pass and it seems so a minor compared to
what these right Wingers are doing and
meanwhile their strategy of continuing
to say the left wants to suppress speech
the left wants to police speech the left
wants to limit this that and the other
thing it is not happening now when they
give examples of when the left does it
it's often things like I said something
transphobic on Twitter
and people piled on and reported me and
maybe Twitter banned me or maybe I just
was attacked on Twitter that's a
violation of my free speech they like to
say but of course the answer the reality
is no that's your free speech coming up
against other people's speech which we
call the consequences to your speech
speech can have consequences that is
dramatically different than Banning
books or limiting drag performances or
whatever the case may be so I'm with the
right Wingers in the sense that we are
seeing a dramatic explosion
of these attempts to censor and to
control and to decide what others can
say and what others can read and what
others can do including parents they
talk about parents rights parents rights
are being curtailed by right-wingers who
say we know better than teachers or
parents what children should be allowed
to read or what sort of performances
children should be allowed to go to they
are right that we are seeing a dramatic
escalation in these efforts but they are
the source of these escalations so this
is one of those situations where the
left needs to be fighting for parents
rights and speech rights and all of
these things but they need to be
fighting for it against those who claim
that it is the left that is perpetuating
these elements and it makes it very
difficult because you get into this
thing where the right will say oh well
but I thought you said there was no
issue I thought you said there was no
issue with well there is no issue from
our side the way you claim and it's
similar to the 2020 election stuff
when people on the left say we need to
make sure that in 2024 the elections not
stolen the right-wingers will say that's
what we're saying no no no no no no no
the right Wingers are the ones who were
making the attempt to seat a president
in the White House who did not win it is
they who we need to be protected against
so let's not lose sight of the ball
let's not be Bamboozled by this
alternate story that is being told by
these folks but let's remember that when
they are aggressively saying the left is
doing something we should explore
whether it is they that are actually
doing that very thing and in this case
it is exactly that Marjorie Taylor green
blurted out classified information at a
public hearing doubled down and said I
don't care the public deserves to know
this is someone who is on the homeland
security committee and she doesn't
believe in the importance of
confidentiality let's take a look at a
video clip in which you will see Marge
divulging classified information at a
hearing about the U.S Mexico border and
uh you will see that when she is told
this is not really the appropriate place
to be talking about that she says I
don't give a damn my words not hurt she
uses other language take a look Chief
Ortiz are you aware that there was an
explosive device found by border patrol
agents on January 17th in an area called
No Man's Land and there's surveillance
of who put it there and guess what it
wasn't Americans it was cartels are you
aware of that
thank you congresswoman and good to see
you again I will tell you that some of
this information that I receive I
receive in a a confidential skip so I'm
going to be a little hesitant of
briefing what I
know and what I don't know with respect
to some of those an event like that I
understand Chief Ortiz but I'm not going
to be confidential because I think
people deserve to know our border patrol
agent should not be in those type of
burger Patrol conditions where they are
at risk of being blown to Pieces by the
cartels who by the way are criminals
mm-hmm
she's not going to be confidential she
has just decided now we'll get to
whether that's something she's allowed
to do as a member of Congress seemingly
doubling down on this she then went to
Tweeter and posted quote if the device
in question was just filled with sand
then why would Chief Ortiz tell me
during his testimony that he was briefed
about it in a skiff and couldn't comment
on classified information then turn
around afterwards and tweet a picture of
it claiming it was filled with sand with
thousands of people and huge amounts of
drugs flooding across the border every
day they don't brief the chief of border
patrol in a skiff about a ball of sand
they only brief us about dangerous
things in classified briefings so she
seems to be acknowledging that it is up
to her to decide what gets to stay
classified and what doesn't now a
reasonable question when we say how how
does government function and of course
if you want to know how government
functions you don't go to Marjorie
Taylor green she doesn't know
um do members of Congress have the
ability you could call it the ability
the right are they are they uh allowed
whatever term you want to use can she
decide unilaterally what gets to remain
confidential and what should be made
public in this way and the answer is of
course as I'm sure many of you suspect
with better instincts than Marjorie
Taylor green the answer is no members of
Congress do not have the ability or the
authority
to declassify classified information on
their own during public hearings it is
important for responsible and sensible
members of Congress to understand they
may be able to discuss certain aspects
of classified or confidential
information they have seen but they
should be careful not to disclose
anything that is still confidential or
classified they can discuss the general
nature of classified information but
should not reveal specific details and
Marjorie Taylor green did everything in
this moment that she is not authorized
to do if a member of the House of
Representatives wants to declassify
information because they believe it is
of public interest or believe it should
be discussed in a public setting the way
Marge seems to believe they have a
protocol and a series of procedures
within the executive branch you submit a
request to the agency that originally
classified the information or you
petition the president for
declassification they claim to be about
Law and Order
and then Marjorie Taylor green says Ah
I've decided I'm not going to be
confidential about this and she does it
brazenly and the saddest part about all
of this is that her followers will
defend anything she does in a vacuum she
and her followers are about Law and
Order and they will say we're about Law
and Order that's why we're against
antifa as they now call it that's why
we're against Hunter Biden you know you
got to investigate Hunter Biden because
of Law and Order and they're all about
Law and Order until all of a sudden Law
and Order would say she's not supposed
to be talking about this and it's
certainly not within her authority to
disclose certain things during a public
hearing no no no no no no no she's doing
the people's work because she's being
transparent and she's informing us oh
well what about her lack of transparency
in this other area when it came to
campaign Finance no that's also okay
there for her not to be transparent
because the campaign Finance rules are
being weaponized against they will
always have some way to get around the
principles that they claim to abide by
Law and Order fiscal conservatism
personal responsibility low regulation
until it conflicts well what about
forcing Twitter to publish anti-vax
stuff
you want to now get involved and say
Twitter you must publish that that's
against your principle of low regulation
well no that's different because big
Tech
Free Speech censoring
oh okay every time you think you've got
them because they violated one of their
own stated principles they just excuse
their way out of it this is the way that
they operate and that's how Marjorie
Taylor Green's followers are reacting to
her just blurting out
classified information and then saying
damn right I did because uh the people
deserve to know if you are listening
today and you'd like to see this clip of
Marjorie Taylor green I don't know why
you would torture yourself like that but
if you did want to we'll have the clip
on our YouTube channel youtube.com the
davidpackman show and we will also have
it on the Spanish YouTube channel at
davidpackman.com Spanish
one of our sponsors today is Bon charge
I have always enjoyed dry saunas you get
in there your heart rate is up dilates
the blood vessels can soothe achy joints
and muscles it's relaxing it's just a
great way to remove a little stress Bon
charge is the creator of the infrared
sauna blanket which you can enjoy from
home super easy to set up heats up fast
you don't have to have your head inside
like at a traditional sauna at the gym
nice for meditating or reading getting
work done relaxing I have found it to be
a great way to unwind at the end of a
long day easy to clean Sleek lightweight
design easy to store and comes with a 12
month warranty and of course if you
don't love it returns are super easy but
I think you will love it go to
boncharge.com Pacman and use the code
pac-man15 for 15 off the link is down
below the David pakman show is a viewer
and listener supported program the the
show we do every day the podcast the
YouTube channel the Spanish dubbing the
TV show the radio show the tick tocks
all of this stuff we have a team and the
primary funding source for all of that
is direct member subscriptions I love
that we make all of this stuff available
for free I also love as we will talk
about with David Sirota in a little bit
when we talk about how we fund what we
do we are mostly funded directly by the
audience the upside of this is there's
no one company or person that can say
we're shutting off the faucet unless you
do XYZ because we spread out our support
through our audience no one entity can
shut us down effectively the
Counterpoint to this is that sometimes
people will email me and they'll say
David
I really didn't like what you said about
whatever I'm canceling my membership yes
we do have to deal with that but we're
in a position not to have to change what
we do because we've upset anybody in
particular leads to some awkward emails
I can tell you uh but I believe that it
is the best way to fund the work that we
do you can sign up at joinpakman.com you
we've got a long list of member benefits
that you can read about there and you
can use the coupon code 24 starts now to
save yourself a it's a substantial
discount let me put it that way I don't
want you know Tish James coming after me
making me the next Target of a grand
jury so I won't tell you how large the
discount is but it's large when you use
the code 24 starts now my pillow appears
to be going broke and CEO Mike Lindell
known to us as Mike pillow or just
pillow was on the Steve Bannon program
explaining what is going on and that he
has had to take out a 10 million dollar
loan to stay afloat folks I take no
pleasure in this I really don't I don't
take pleasure in this but actions of
consequences there can be a reaction to
the things you say and do and it can be
bad for your business let's take a look
at this clip here is Mike pillow
revealing that pillow Enterprises my
pillow is at significant risk here and
just to keep things going and make
payroll apparently with his 1500
employees he had to take out a loan look
at this about I guess your loan the loan
you took out at uh at my pillow people
people are all over you about this did
he say the loan you took out at Mike
pillow
yeah there last year actually was three
separate loans as the as the machine
companies continue to sue us for oh my
God he's blaming the machines billions
of dollars and um we had to borrow
almost 10 million dollars that my pillow
were a company we're an employee-owned
company I just baffles me Steve you've
got all these companies are these
machine companies out there these voting
machine companies that nobody even knew
their name before but everybody protects
them and yet you attack a USA company my
pillow and my employees and it's just
disgusting yeah so apparently he's
taking his uh anger out on the machine
we're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines so listen I've
interviewed pillow a couple of times and
the last time he was on I did ask him
about the financial impact of this
tomfoolery and he told me I've spent
about 35 million dollars so I when he
told me 35 million I think he was
talking about
these were it's like do words have
meaning investigating
quote voter fraud
as well as on lawyers and traveling
around and all of this different stuff
he always had the choice to stop or
never begin this stuff in the first
place it is totally on him and blaming
others again they espouse personal
responsibility and then they blame
others in this case he's blaming
inanimate objects he's blaming the
machines the real tragedy
is that as a result of this nonsense his
1500 employees could end up out of jobs
I'm not gloating here it doesn't make me
happy I don't want people to lose their
jobs or struggle to pay their bills but
this is the free market that they admire
and get on their knees and pray at the
altar of don't let them trick you this
had trouble written all over it when
pillow showed up at the White House this
was very early in covet I guess it would
have been uh 20 2020 right he showed up
at the White House and said Trump was a
gift from God as president or whatever
it was that he said exactly and we're
going to be making masks some of our
pillow factories or whatever the promise
was by the way did they ever make the
masks I don't know I never heard about
masks coming from pillows Factory and
it's been downhill ever since so it's
not about woohoo 1500 people might lose
their jobs it's about actions have
consequences and uh apparently the
combination of
him spending what a couple of months ago
was already 35 million on this crusade
to try to overturn an election that
doesn't need to be overturned uh
combined with I would guess some
deleterious impact on sales as a result
of the fact that he has alienated at
least half the country from ever buying
his products and to be honest even some
Republicans I think now would say I'm
not that's the crazy pillow guy with the
machines I'm not buying up that pillow
I'll get a different pillow how good
could his pillow really be and people
write to me and say it's not actually
that great that is the impact those are
the repercussions of what he did
everyone allowed him to speak however he
wanted and his speech included going on
TV making wild claims about the election
hiring lawyers getting cyber guys having
his Symposium as he would call it and
now that had an impact in other people
they're speaking and the way that some
businesses have spoken I forget which
ones but a bunch of retail stores said
we don't want the pillows anymore they
spoke by saying we don't want to do
business with you anymore everybody gets
to speak
it's a beautiful thing and the speech
that you choose to engage in can have
consequences it's a sad thing but it
looks like my pillow may be going broke
Donald Trump is panicking and switching
into horse face mode referring to Stormy
Daniels now exclusively as horse face he
used to first it was Stormy Daniels then
it was Stormy horse-faced Daniels and
now it is just horse face in a global
humiliation of trump panicking I would
say he's red in the face but because
he's so orange you can't tell about the
possibility that he may be indicted in
connection with the entire Stormy
Daniels Affair and it's it's an affair
both in the sense that it is an incident
and it is a it is an affair also in the
sense that Trump had an affair with
Stormy Daniels look at this Insanity
that happened this morning and over the
last 24 hours with Donald Trump this is
a man who is not well and he's arguably
on the edge not only of major legal
trouble
but he seems to be close to a complete
and total mental breakdown panicking and
Furious about everything even things he
has misunderstood which is really the
summary of Modern Republicanism we are
Furious about things we either misheard
misinterpreted or flat out don't
understand take a look at this Trump
posting to truth social essential quote
I did nothing wrong in the horse face
this is a former president I did nothing
wrong in the horse face case I see she
showed up in New York today trying to
drum up some publicity for herself I
haven't seen or spoken to her since I
took a picture with her on a golf course
in full golf gear including a hat close
to 18 years ago I guess he's saying if
he was wearing golf gear they couldn't
possibly have engaged in sexual
intercourse she knows nothing about me
well she she actually seems to know some
intimate things about Trump she knows
nothing about me other than her con man
lawyer avenadi misspelled and convicted
liar and felon jailbird Michael Cohen
may have schemed up
never had an affair with her just
another false acquisition by a capital S
sleaze bag Witch Hunt I assume Trump
means a false accusation but he called
it an acquisition can you imagine a
guiltier sounding statement than this I
was wearing so many clothes around her
that there's no way anything happened
and also her face is a horse face so
she's not attractive enough I guess for
Trump to have had an affair with her now
the other thing a couple people emailed
me about is to what degree is Trump
focusing on this term Affair like in
Trump's mind maybe affair
means something different than an
isolated sexual encounter
I don't know I don't know whether
there's some kind of technicality there
Trump continuing and then switching over
to his other Obsession Ron DeSantis
saying quote in addition to wanting to
cut Social Security
and raise the minimum age to at least 70
and Medicare Rhino Ron Des sanctimonious
is delivering the biggest insurance
company bailout to globalist insurance
companies in history he's also crushed
Florida homeowners whose houses were
destroyed in the capital H hurricane
they're getting Pennies on the dollar
his insurance commissioner does nothing
while Florida's lives are ruined this is
the worst capital I Insurance capital S
scam in the entire Capital C country and
then lastly just hours ago turning caps
lock on and completely off the wall
posting quote the fake investigations by
radical left Democrat prosecutors are
nothing other than election interference
into the politics of a failing Nation
Maga now I want to
try to be really
crystal clear here
it is okay to acknowledge
that there is a comedic element here
when you hear Trump trump a trunk when
you hear Trump talk about Ron Des
Sanctus and use the term horse face in a
serious Manner and all these things
there I understand that there's you know
76 year old man sort of like screaming
at clouds with nicknames and insults and
he's he's dark orange and he's sweating
and he's mistaking words and Furious at
whoever's running the teleprompter like
there's a hugely comedic element here
but we also need to not allow the
cartoonish comedy of it
to get in the way of remembering that
this man was President for four years he
had access to the most sensitive
information he had access at least
theoretically to the nuclear nuclear
codes and could have launched nuclear
weapons he was the head of state in the
sense of running foreign policy for a
while even though he understood nothing
that's not funny
and we don't want to let the humor of it
and I agree there's humor it's okay to
recognize the humor of it and sometimes
we recognize the humor so that we laugh
instead of cry I get it we don't want to
let that
minimize the danger of this man in our
minds and Sam Harris recently spoke
about this and whatever you think about
Sam Harris every once in a while Sam
Harris has some extraordinarily
prescient points uh Sam Harris spoke
about this recently we can't let the
humor get in the way of the fact that
this is crazy and dangerous all caps
horse face the Sanctus all this
difference yeah okay I get it but this
is a very dangerous person and if he
were to become president again it would
potentially be disastrous for the United
States and for the world we'll have more
on this on our Instagram search
Instagram for David packman show you'll
find plenty there
it's great to welcome back to the
program today David Sirota who is a
journalist columnist and founder and
editor of the lever which you can find
at levernews.com it's been a little
while since since we had you on and
you've been busy but it's really great
to have you on thanks thanks for thanks
so much for having me so I mean let's
just kind of start start at the top here
what was the goal with creating the
lever what are the issues in the media
landscape that you're hoping to solve or
improve upon or or address
sure I mean I I had been working for
Bernie Sanders uh as his speech writer
on the 2020 presidential campaign but
before that I spent many years as a
journalist uh and um after the campaign
I I decided to do some writing and you
know it actually started out as a as
just a small sub stack um but there was
a lot of reader support for it uh and so
I teamed up with uh a former a reporter
that I had formerly worked with Andrew
Perez uh to start doing some actual
reporting uh and from there it kind of
grew uh and and look I think that what
what our focus is what a lever story is
is a story that's about
um it's about following the money uh
it's about following the power uh our
our mission is to actually change the
conversation and change the policies in
this country so we don't pretend to just
be you know uh uh reporting whatever is
going on we our reporting is
accountability journalism designed to
hold politicians accountable when it
comes to issues that deal with money and
power so for instance in the last uh
month or so we broke open the story of
the deregulatory decisions that were
made on rail safety in the lead up to
the East Palestine Ohio derailment we
this week we spend a lot of time
breaking open stories about the
regulatory decisions that were made to
deregulate Silicon Valley Bank uh at
what were the decisions made by
politicians for which donors so we are
constantly asking the question who are
public officials actually serving we are
constantly spotlighting that so with the
idea that the more that the readership
knows the more that the readership can
be engaged to actually pressure their
lawmakers to do to make better decisions
so so how is this funded because one of
the interesting things is particularly
when the focus is to follow the money
and to have accountability my guess is
you have to be particularly careful
about following the money when it comes
to your organization as well yeah I mean
we're look we're readers supported
um we work with other media Outlets like
Jacobin as an example syndicates our
work some some of our work appears in
the guardian so so we have a kind of
we're I mean we're small right so we're
trying to to build out but we we are a
reader supported news organization uh
that holds them accountable holds them
being the proverbial them uh meaning uh
corporations politicians and the like uh
and I think that what you'll see is is
that on our stories one thing that I'm
really proud of on our stories is I
think when you read our stories you
don't have to trust us right because
what we do in every story and we take a
lot of time to do this is to link to all
of the primary sources in which we are
referring to so I say this all the time
if you read one of our stories oh you
know saroda is this so wrote is that Hey
listen that's fine you can believe
whatever you want about me
the links to the source materials are
all there for you to evaluate I fully
believe in in I don't even believe in
trust but verify I believe first and
foremost in verified right so when you
read one of our stories when you see it
linked to all the that Source material
that's because we're trying to show the
reader Hey listen if you don't trust us
about a statement an assertion that we
make here a statement a fact that we
make here go make you can go fact check
us and we have a vigorous fact checking
uh a process in what we do but that
that's the point here is that I think
that that we in a lot of ways we in in
media uh the media ecosystem has gotten
away from that uh which has uh created a
an environment in which people can say
oh that's you know quote unquote fake
news so the way we combat that is to try
to present all of our facts uh and be
very open and transparent about that so
you can debate you know this or that
about the writer or about the public
application but you can't debate the
documents and facts what are your
thoughts on whether there can be other
funding methods for organizations like
yours or mine or larger Media or
whatever that you find journalistically
ethical or kosher or what whatever word
you might want to apply to it in the
sense of if there's any kind of
advertising is that necessarily a
problem or does it depend on the subject
matter that is being covered and the
types of products and services being
advertised or like what what other
models are okay in your mind
that's a great question I mean to my
mind I am look I am we don't have
corporate ads and the like but I I I'm
not a purist when it comes to this uh I
I'm not a purist when it comes to
Foundation funding I'm not a purist when
it comes to uh uh you know in individual
donors uh I think that we live in a
world of unfortunately where uh getting
resources to do public interest
journalism there is no Public Funding
for that uh in any kind of institutional
level there is in a sense of
crowdsourcing it but that is a very very
tough uh tough road it's a worthwhile
road we we are on that road as as in as
an entity so it's hard for me to create
you know hard and fast rules other than
to say this I think being reader
supported at some capacity is impor
important uh and having that be a major
pillar of a media organization is
extremely important for many reasons one
of which is you want to be serving a
readership uh and at least have that be
a a a huge pillar of what you are who
you are answering to for the resources
to do journalism I also think uh that
that that having reader support uh is
actually over the Long Haul if you can
do it uh is actually more stable uh in
the sense of a lot of small uh
comparatively small uh contributors uh
becomes a more stable funding base than
one or two or three uh huge funders or
huge corporations that can wake up on on
a given day and just pull funding right
so I think there's a stability issue
there yeah one of the things about that
that's interesting which I've talked
with my audience about and I think most
recently somewhere between 38 and 40
percent of our total revenue comes from
direct subscriptions from people in the
sort of style you're talking about is
it's on the one hand of it Bob and
Brenda can directly support the work I'm
doing rather than whoever else go
corporate entity or whatever on the
other side of it because Bob and Brenda
are are just two people who I love Bob
and Brenda are great they're also not
going to be able to get me to change
what I'm doing with the threat that they
will pull their five bucks a month
that's that that's absolutely right I
mean it's a kind of Diversified
portfolio model which is which is what I
like and maybe the the hard and fast
rule is kind of this is that if you have
a diversified
um uh funding based resource base that
is not singularly reliant on any of the
categories uh that is I think the ideal
I mean the ideal ideal is to have it be
purely individual small subscription
based uh to fund a giant Newsroom I
don't think anybody has been able to do
that yet and maybe we're on our way to
that who knows but no one has as real as
to my mind has really been able to do
exactly that so so one level down from
that is okay how can I put together
um some major donors foundations not
non-profit foundations a subscription
base so that so that the publication
doesn't have to singularly answer to any
one of those entities that's about as
independent I I think that I mean that's
pretty good and again I'm not I'm not a
purist on this what what I want to see I
mean right now we live in a world of
course that's so far from Pure we live
in a world where where media is is
dominated by huge corporate entities
with either you know singular
billionaires at the top of them
Bloomberg News and the like uh or
massive corporations uh that are that
are making the decisions uh those aren't
those aren't really Diversified uh at
all it's very clear who they answer to
in fact a lot some of these Publications
put right underneath the top of their
articles presented by Chevron right now
there's you know I guess in some ways
kudos to them for at least being
transparent sure about that but they're
also being explicit about who they
actually serve uh and I think ultimately
you can see the independence of media
by the content that the media is
producing I go back to what we produce I
I don't think anybody could do could
read what what we do and say oh we go
easy on this or that entity or this or
that faction uh uh for for this or that
reason and we are trying to follow the
money no matter where it goes I mean we
have been critical of the progressive
caucus at times we have obviously been
critical of the Republicans at times
we've been critical of of uh corporate
Democrats at times and when I say we've
been critical what I mean is our
reporting is holding them accountable
it's not just us going out and saying
you know they're jerks or whatever it's
us actually holding them accountable and
last thing on this I think even though
we have a lack of media literacy in in
some senses in this country a lot of
media consumers intuitively can tell the
difference between when Deepwater
Horizon is going on Anderson Cooper goes
to a break and there's a BP ad right on
the one hand and then on the other hand
in an article that you do about uh the
derailment there might be you
recommending a shaving razor or
something like that I think people would
be able to distinguish which one is
potentially directly related to the
stories that are being reported and how
versus things that are not that that
look that that's absolutely right so so
when people ask me you know would you
ever take you know advertising whichever
you know I'm like well would I ever take
advertising from Chevron no right right
like like
that's problematic uh so but but I think
there's there's huge gradations and I
and I really I want to reiterate this I
I I I I I truly don't think Purity uh
and I'm putting that in quotes is a way
to look at this if we want to build a a
healthy Independent Media
in a country that does not offer
institutional Public Funding for media
right uh we're gonna have to try to find
models and formulas that allow us to do
that and that and where it doesn't take
15 or 20 years to build out fully a a an
individual subscriber base that can
support a 100 200 300 person Newsroom
like like climate change is not waiting
for us to to do that and and look I'm
really proud of the of the reader
support that we have uh I'm really uh uh
uh encouraged by the Grassroots reader
support that other uh Independent Media
like like your show like like other
shows have been able to generate in
recent years it is a long hard slog it
is inherently a long hard slog uh and
and we don't have time to wait I was
going to talk a little bit about
sourcing but I think it might be more
interesting instead to get your thoughts
about Nuance maybe is the way I would
put it you know one of the things that's
really tough with stories that are more
complicated than the simplest of
simplest stories which is really most of
them is that oftentimes when you
introduce Nuance or you revise your
views you are potentially accused of
either flip-flopping or you were
originally lying or or you're
backpedaling or whatever the case may be
this comes up a lot of times with
messages I get about covet vaccines
about but David you said one thing in
2021 and now you're saying something
else and you have to sort of explain
well listen
the vaccine in 2021 based on the variant
that was out there was very effective at
preventing transmission and infection
the virus that is out there has changed
the vaccines have been updated and it is
now more a tool for preventing death and
hospitalization and not really a tool
for preventing oh so you're back
pedaling is
how what's the best way for people in my
position or in your position to deal
with this bearing in mind that we always
want to be communicating the best
information we have at the time and we
want to be completely honest but we also
know that the appetite for nuance is
maybe more limited than we would like it
to be yeah it's a great that's a really
really great question
um well first and foremost I think we
have to understand that there is a
learning process as we learn new
information uh conclusions will change I
mean that's that that's part of The
Human Experience anybody who who doesn't
want to learn new information and thus
change conclusions is I mean you're
heading straight into denialism right so
I don't think it's I don't think media
should participate in any kind of
denialism uh at all I think I think the
other point about this is to is actually
to what we try to do in our reporting I
always say this to my reporters is to
State what we know as a fact right now
yeah don't foreclose on the idea that
the facts in the future can change but
also don't say things that can that are
not grounded in facts that are that
can't be verified so you know did X lead
to why did this deregulation lead to
This Disaster you can only really say
that
if you can prove it but you can say
these senators or these lawmakers
ignored warnings about this outcome to
cast votes for that kind of deregulation
and then this happened right now so my
point is is that that's a Nuance but
it's it's an important Point as long as
you're saying what can be factually
verified I think that's the obligation
and the I mean that is the job of
Journalism is to say what we know to be
true without speculating or
extrapolating it's when you get into
extrapolating ahead in the future uh
that it becomes problematic then it can
become I mean I hate this term but then
it can become success susceptible to the
charge of quote unquote fake news
nothing is fake news if you're stating
in this document or on this day this
thing happened and you can pretend it
didn't happen but that's like pretending
the sky isn't blue that's to me the the
role of the journalist yeah and to stick
with the covet examples that was
frequently it came up when people would
call me about hydroxychloroquine or
Ivermectin or whatever and it's I'm not
going to say this does not work what I
can tell you is we don't have the type
of evidence now that medical science
requires to say that it works could that
evidence be presented in the future from
a study that hasn't yet been done sure
but of course again it's all about
whether the audience you have is
receptive to that and I think part of
hopefully what we are doing is
cultivating such an audience that
understands those those nuances
absolutely and I think I think that's
actually part of I mean there's kind of
like what we're doing on a day-to-day
basis reporting a story on Silicon
Valley Bank reporting a story on the
decisions and the lead up to the East
Palestine disaster but I think over the
Long Haul what we're also doing what
Independent Media is doing uh is saying
that media needs to go back not that
everything was better before but there
needs to be a reconnection with the idea
that media's job is to hold accountable
those
of all parties without regard to party
without regard uh to uh kind of tribal
politics we're going to hold people
accountable to the facts as we know them
now and if the facts change in the
future or there's new facts that arise
we're going to report on those two we've
been speaking with David Sirota who's
founder and editor of the lever you can
find more at levernews.com always
appreciate your time and insights thank
you thanks so much for having me
we have not spoken about George Anthony
devolder Santos the lying Republican
Congressman for some period of time but
there are even more new scandals related
to Santos I do think it would be great
for him to resign it would be better
even for him to be forced out but it is
not at all apparent that there is an
interest among the Republican party in
doing that George Santos has actually
filed for re-election although it is
considered more uh of a technical thing
than any real desire to actually run in
2024 in order to keep his I believe it's
his campaign fund going or there was
some sort of technical Finance reason
why he did that let's start with the
first story George Santos is now accused
of orchestrating a credit card skimming
operation credit card skimming operation
which schemed to steal information from
ATM and credit cards this is according
to a sworn statement from a former
roommate of his obtained by Politico the
Declaration from this man who said he
met Santos when he rented a room in
Florida from the now Congressman states
he was accused of a federal crime of
credit card fraud in 2017 and pleaded
guilty the man Trella who's from Brazil
served seven months in prison and was
then deported his attorney sent the
letter to the FBI U.S attorney's office
for the eastern district of New York and
Secret Service in New York on Wednesday
Trella said Santos was known to him as
Anthony devolder another name tied to
Santos he added that he learned from
Santos how to clone ATM and credit cards
after he started renting the room from
him quote Santos taught me how to skim
card information and how to clone cards
he gave me all the material and taught
me how to put skimming devices and
cameras on ATM machines he said Santos
had a warehouse in Orlando Florida this
is if this is true this is a
professional criminal I really want
people to understand that this is a
professional criminal if this is true
Santos had a warehouse in Orlando that
housed materials such as printers blank
ATM and credit cards that could be
painted and engraved with stolen account
and personal information the way this
kind of works and sometimes you hear
there's these like scarce things about
this but this stuff does exist
you can put a device on top of an ATM
this rarely would happen if you go to
like a Wells Fargo ATM inside you know
you have to swipe your use your ATM card
just to even get in and all that it's
unlikely this would happen there but I'm
sure many of you are familiar with these
kind of like lower end ATMs where you
might go to like a cash only dive bar
and they go cash only and you're like I
don't have any cash and they go ATM
right there those types of ATMs in the
corner of a bar for example and others
are the more likely ATMs to be targeted
by this sort of thing and sometimes what
happens is they put a device on top of
where you would insert or swipe your
card and when you do that it gathers the
information and then you type in your
pin and there might be a camera where
they take up they see you typing the pin
or maybe the device itself there's
different versions of this but it's
usually those types of independent ATMs
in general at a mall potentially Etc
I've at least not heard of it happening
like at a bank ATM anyway the idea here
is that he was installing these things
trellis said he went to Seattle began to
steal credit card information from ATM
terminals with the deal that the profits
would be split between he and Santos he
decried that Santos threatened his
friends after he was arrested to not
tell authorities that Santos was
actually the one in charge Trella
claimed Santos stole the money he
collected for his bail he said he has
other Witnesses who can back it all up
this is a sworn statement a sworn
statement so this is the latest Scandal
involving George Anthony devolder Santos
this is not surprising like he's a lying
fraudster in many ways and so committing
actual criminal fraud would not come as
a surprise to me at all there seems to
be something kind of compulsive about it
compulsive lying is when you just you
you just make up lies on the spot it's
not even clear why you're lying about
this stuff and it seems as though he may
have some kind of compulsion to fraud
and criminality of different kinds he's
really the epitome of the Maga candidate
right make America grift again just a
liar and a fraudster
all the way through as a reminder how
can a sitting member of the House be
removed there aren't too many ways
either the House of Representative votes
to expel him with a two-thirds vote very
very rare usually only when there is
like conviction on criminal activity
um and then failure to be re-elected
which you can't really take action on
until 2024. so that's where we are right
now on Santos and it doesn't end there
I'm going to be honest with you I don't
even totally understand this story fully
yet
it appears as though George Anthony
devolder Santos lying Republican
Congressman
brokered the sale of a 19 million dollar
yacht
what I I know it just it doesn't make
any sense but this is now the latest
bizarre thing involving this guy the New
York Times reports that just before his
house election Santos helped two of his
largest donors reach a private deal
on a 19 million dollar luxury yacht
um this has captured the attention of
federal and state authorities that are
investigating Santos the sale was not
previously reported is one of about a
dozen different leads being pursued by
the FBI the U.S attorney's Office in
Brooklyn and the Nassau County District
Attorney's Office prosecutors and FBI
agents have sought in recent weeks to
question the new new owner of the 141
Foot super yacht Raymond tantillo a Long
Island auto dealer about the boat and is
dealings with Santos and his fundraising
efforts tantillo bought the boat from
Myra Ruiz a republican donor in Miami
Santos negotiated the payment what the
hell is going on the payment was 12 and
a quarter million up front and six and a
half million more in installments and
advised the two of the logistics of
turning over the yacht this took place
just a few weeks before the election
what
it's not clear what laws if any were
broken several election law experts say
that if the sale was designed to inject
money into Santos's campaign it may
violate federal law governing caps on
campaign contributions it would also
could be illegal if Santos tied any
commission he received on the sale to
previous or future donations even if no
laws were broken it is more evidence of
an emerging Narrative of people in his
orbit that Santos used his campaign not
only to win but also as a networking
exercise to ingratiate himself with Rich
donors and to enrich himself through a
lawyer representing him uh in potential
criminal matters Santos has denied a
declined to comment but denied
wrongdoing
uh this is crazy and of course the
biggest story is this paragraph right
here a central mystery like there's a
bigger story here about the money with
Santos a central mystery writes the New
York Times is Santos's sudden
unexplained jump in income and where he
got the money to load him loan himself
about seven hundred thousand dollars for
the 2022 campaign in 2020 he reported an
income of 55 000 two years later he
reported a salary of three quarters of a
million and over a million in dividends
from his company the florida-based
devolder organization
descent Santo De Santos Santos described
it as a capital introduction into the
business
um
this is this is really crazy oh one
other element here Santo said publicly
that his company broker deals between
High net worth clients in an interview
with semaphore in December he explained
his work saying if a client wants to
sell a plane or boat he puts a feeler
out there adding that he's landed some
million dollar contracts if you're
looking at a 20 million dollar yacht my
referral fee there can be anywhere
between 200 and 400 000 it turns out
that he did deal uh in a yacht worth
almost 20 million dollars this is just a
really sketchy guy compulsive liar drawn
to behavior that is at minimum on the
edges of legal and we'll find out
potentially actually against the law I
told you weeks ago we are not at the end
of The George Santos stories and clearly
we are not at the end of The George
Santos stories you want to see what
happens when your brain gets infected by
Maga brain worms well I have a voicemail
for you today
it's been a while since we did one like
this we have a voicemail number that
number is 2192 David P
here is a caller suffering from very
severe Maga brain worms a sad condition
I don't think Ivermectin or hydroxy will
cure it
hey Mr David white girl Pac-Man lifter
so that's Mr David white guilt Pacman
libtard I know it was hard to hear it
sounded like white Gert but that's what
he said I can't wait till we get a test
in California or New York or Florida so
you can
so all the men can say that they're all
females as soon as we get attacked right
and then no all the men will say they
are females when they get attacked so
they don't have to serve in the military
but as far as I knew women did serve in
the military
because everyone's a female using your
logic because you're a white
guilt lives hard so interestingly a lot
of my haters say I'm not white because
I'm Jewish this is a really interesting
thing actually there is disagreement
um on whether Jews are white because the
right-wing neo-nazis left to say no no
no no no Jews are not white but the
right Wingers who don't like Jews
because Jews generally are quite
Progressive one of the most Progressive
voting blogs love to say Jews are just
privileged white guilt white people that
doesn't understand
oh I can't wait wait yeah that's what
it's going to take for a live tours like
you you guys are gonna oh it's gonna
take a
attack on the Homeland for you guys to
realize that the genders are gonna go
into their actual roles men are going to
be men women are going to be women it's
going to take that only for you white
guilt tars that are ruining the
world
trying to socially engineer everyone oh
God it's gonna be
well it's gonna be next level all right
so this guy seems very excited about an
attack on the Homeland that he believes
is coming I don't know how you cure that
I'm not even going to weigh in I don't
know how you cure that we have a great
bonus show today I won't even tell you
what's on it because it's so explosive
but I hope you'll join me you can sign
up at joinpakman.com and you will
instantly instantly get access to the
bonus check